okay okay so our four is dealing with
different types of data mass spec data
ingest sequencing it would be where they
seek the genetic data like chip seek
information data so small enables
libraries of smoke of maleficents
three-dimensional structures of proteins
and the general task is to integrate all
this baby because what researcher
typically has this as a set of different
types of a different nature and they
would like to understand what what
actually what the meaning of all set and
this is what we bring they integration
and it means that based on making
different types of people understand
what kind of specificity visions okay so
the next slide
thanks Lee
yes so this is a mainly use of the
processing of different types of GS data
like transcriptomics genomics and
epigenetics unsupervised analysis of
junk irony of the DNA with the genomics
and things like that
including single-cell analysis of signal
cell phones
the next section is must be drama free
robux sweet mention structures who small
bedevils libraries of small molecules 3d
structure proteins the next that
integration in modeling and we have a
systems biology section where several
models are studied and in my own job
also studying with wireless revolution
mutation variants and cell culture
images and probably most important is
that Association section where we're
different monkey on the different sorts
of Maki omics data could be integrated
with with some some biological
conclusions and demonstrated and that
the mining standard other tools okay
Computer Sciences hope that my ninja
statistics is machine learning
okay so so all things around
unsupervised analysis supervisor
Martin's plus three is the nation
classification seems like that okay
makes light please
okay so this is a logical scheme of some
particle analysis this is given cases
sister and they seek a logical graph of
our amazing analysis so first you care
for all theta
after that you are leaning sit on the
left for DC are artifacts errors if
possible after that detection of red
zones probably not not defined
GTF file detection of exon Junction
based based on mentee and a game based
on making as a for construction after
that a table of expression for either
Foreman genes I suppose splice variance
of course more normal biological sex and
differential expression makes life
next what next life video okay this is
how this logical scheme looks in reality
the interface of the section so that the
main idea is to make life easy for for
biology meaning you are starting we
start with start button and after that
the system is is supporting showing what
next button would be present each button
is an algorithm so just first column of
buttons
this is pre-processing sing different
types of pre-processing including that a
smooth each and J's that finish next
column is error correction since Mexico
is maybe and by different algorithms
detection of exhaust as enrichment of
genomic regions and probably it could be
not putting holidays not reported in the
GTF file either for construction table
of expression of transcripts of exons
genes and differentiation so just
clicking buttons biologists biologists
will create the pipeline and after that
run okay even without understanding what
actually she is do it because the system
is supporting and saying what what
button can be pressed next and on to
second get some results okay next next
next level
one of the section of the platform is is
a single cell transcriptome analysis of
single cell fronts get this is this is
now is it's becoming most popular topic
and people are very interested in that
so we we have a section for analysis of
neck next slide
okay statistically since sake of the
sickle cell beta is highly noisy some a
lot of statistical challenges including
treats in assigning greeks to transcribe
supermarket also assigning grades
through to cells and so on when
education organizations until clustering
of cells based on profile of gene
expression and with differentiation
between master so each classroom would
be specific cell cells and after that
Rizzoli
and all of that is can be done with with
a similar type of interface again the
user started with start button and after
that the system is just showing your
what depresses ok please next slide
okay here this is a result actually so
on the left you have a portion of
buttons
all of them are clustering algorithms
each button is an operator on the left
upper left corner and on the right the
visualization sees from PC to T Essen
okay and the typical picture will be on
the right so you have cells which are
grouped in clusters and after that the
next step is to understand what the
meaning of each cluster but whatever
cells okay next next libraries
the important part of the story is
analysis of junk they may related to to
assembly more Samsung come know it could
be the Nova transcriptome assembly could
be minor beyond or it can be just just
repeats or to the pieces of transposons
in RNA data or daily next okay here what
we get into platform are two basic
approaches they're very known software
tools called three this is what is shown
which is has three steps for assembly
transcriptome or any kind of expressed
items and our own approach this isn't
next slide which is based on the big
clusters next slide okay so the cluster
is is a sort of Association so we have
for each or a or any sequences and we
get K mirrors so the task is to find a
group of King nerves and a group of
sequences which are closely associated
what does it means for instance that
each caner
is participating in 80 percent of all
the sequences of the set and each set
has 70% of Kaymer's it's a king from the
chaos
this arrangement this association group
of Association
again sicknesses we could bite big
buster
and after that we are playing with the
cluster performing assembly next like
this it could be two types of assembly
one type is is looking for repeats
something which is something creative in
in reads it could be some portions of
reads which I rented it if it could be
really beats like I knew it I knew it so
cosine line or it can be some highly
expressed for instance on particularly
okay after clustering because those so
each big cluster is an element and after
that we are playing some special
clustering okay which is dealing with
big data and the clusters are clustered
based on shared kingdoms for instance
immunities and after said all assembly
is pure food by the growing graph method
only with Keener's so this came as first
filter type in clusters and by the last
thing called the clusters and after that
inside each cluster these came ears are
a set and this assembly is some
consensus over in before whatever with
next slide please
alternative approach this is
transcriptome assembly where we want
longer sentence who say repeats are
relatively short and that transcript
could be good below so again the same
clustering is if Y here but instead of
this bursting paste is not on cleaners
but based on sequences on rates so two
big clusters
are linked together or clustered
together if they share reach in center
okay and again after that after after
finding clusters of the clusters only
King air sources of these clusters are
used for a set and this assembly of
course much more trust the loop because
came ears are preciate very they are
participated in many in many areas in
many seasons mixed language okay a
couple of words about clustering
algorithm which we develop and it works
in any metric space it means that you
need only a distance for instance for
big clusters we do not have some errand
space you have just a distance between
because nose distance it could be
similarity or similarity between the
clusters can be based on k-mers on all
based on rate so the idea is that taking
specific points as centers and how to
select a specific for instance a special
algorithm after that the maple is is
every neighborhood of the set of points
point is studied in terms of just a
fractal dimension is the data for this
neighborhood and after that for this
fractal dimension enrichment from Port
Fourchon pivotal point of view
enrichment of this neighborhood is
completely so the best the best original
is taking as
of this central point and opposite both
central all these neighborhoods are
combined together by
several missiles in order to get
separated wasps and this clustering
algorithms is applied to many kind of
requesting from bursting of just
sequences to clustering of big clusters
or clustering small malevolence and okay
any sort of object where a distance
could be defined somehow okay the next
word please
okay what we have in processing
processing will genitally for instance
this receipt is repeat data for DNA
methylation so if you look to the first
line of blue squares so we have raw
reads after that it would be specific
making this elite reads on the genome
separation of read alignments to
strength after that calculation of
scores for per position preposition
iteration scores for both strands and
after that segmentation of of the genome
sequencing in order to find enriched
regions in rich friend which are
enriched by by little agencies and the
lower line of blue squares is something
similar but already for controls
between treatment and control we're not
a score of methylation is completely but
a score of differentiation between
treatment and control this way okay next
slide please
okay so the major point here is scoring
so the scoring is based on some
statistics
this is statistics based on boots the
serum for a local love likelihood ratio
and with with some tweaks with medical
tricks we can show that that the
statistics is specific transformation
castilian specific statistics is
normally distributed normally normally
Mississippi after the organization of to
normal distribution we can actually
calculate a difference of this normal
distribution normalized already with the
same average with the same mean and the
same variance and and it will be after
dividing two square root of two it will
take a normal distribution or one and
with that we can get a score for
differentiation and treatment a control
so for just for treatment in order to
find enriched enriched position just
only once that this disease is completed
and it's that this statistic depends on
how far observed frequency is from from
zero driven from from now people and for
differentiation we have to complain to
statistics and dr. Z transform into
different statistics and the gain
score which is normally the CPU but it
means that as some period okay next next
slide please
okay so our algorithm for segmentation
is a specific one it was published 2010
and the meaning is that this is this is
binary search route where first we are
looking for the most enriched fragments
of the fragment of the genome which is
most unreached by by some signal
differentiation signal or or initial
signal for methylation after that we are
looking for the next fragment not
intersecting with researchers which is
also enriched second level of enrichment
and so on and the trick here that it can
be done very in the first way log into n
operations and very appearance it means
that we very accurately can detect the
margins of of the fragments with some
special algorithm which is published
okay
so by this way we can find with high
precision what what friend in terms that
you know arbitrary and this algorithm
actually is used not only for thinning
innovation but also for for analysis of
cheap seek theta and for copy number
variation signals and many different
signals which are distributed or
residual okay next next slide please
okay his histone modification signal so
chip 6c and with with this algorithm we
have in the pipeline several algorithms
our own and public domain several public
appearance as well as in this little
Asian bye-bye section platform okay so
with our algorithm we got very good
detection of typical size of nucleus
always with request a summary with this
be mess okay
the segmentation of and the segmentation
of course is happening come to strengths
and dr. Z the entire nucleus on the
right side upper class room is detected
as a portion of do not oppose these
negative mix like this
their army analysis of irony anything
bigger
we never gained several approaches
public domain approaches like Jeremy or
Jacuzzi we're in one of them you have to
have not only Rene seek data but also
the ENIAC in order to distinguish
between Aaron a and S&P sniffs our
algorithm which is based on some
specific on this honest statistics
similar to what they show view with
ceramic based artistic swim is normal
distribution and typically we don't have
the innovative we're just saying that if
frequency okay
or score most of these days is not high
enough then provinces is ever made and
this inference this is extremely right
then that progress is this isn't okay
next slide please
actually the same statistics is a right
to detection of somatic mutation where
we are playing with with statistics in
normals sample if you were sample and
plane would set in a special manner we
can say if there is a difference between
Cuba and North or there is no difference
this is this is our approach but also we
have several public domain algorithms
pipelines which can reduce
okay now the we topic of the story the
next slide please
integration of multi will be performance
data and in either case somehow linking
them to to clinically or at least to
specificity of patients so all of that
is based on pains on tables on a
different on its data for instance we
can have a table of mutations on the web
jet jet just present exits or enrichment
of some fragments by mutations this is
also good comics comics data enrichment
of fragments by by by mutations gene
expression data it could be either form
expression data it can be related or
expression of microarray name and give
different types of things including even
ICP 54 for some drugs so how to combine
all of that together and here what what
approach we are using it in the bathroom
next like this so this is conceptual
idea
the conceptual idea is based on a matrix
of distances between samples or between
pages so for instance on the Left we
have a table of expression values for
different sentence ABC based on all
genes we can calculate something like a
classic clustering three four pages and
it will be something some some patients
or some samples samples will be
rude actually this is a judge based on
the distance methods in basis according
to all genes here the major major work
is home okay next next slide please
now if we will take a subset of genes so
according to all genes
it will be one type of clustering of
centers on the right according to one
subset of genes then it will be it will
be good it could be different type of
cluster different type of distance
methods and accordingly to yellow subset
of genes it can be certain that the
requester
okay where is the truth the next next
slide please
the truth is coming from combining
different omics data together for
instance we have a table with the same
sentence of gene expression and the
table with again the same sentence of
something else like metabolics
abundance of metabolites how to
understand what clustering is is true
but there is like that let us try to
find a subset of genes yellow one or
orange one and a subset of metabolites
again orange one which equals a sub set
the clustering trees or distance
matrices between centers are very
similar
if says very similar we have triple
association may be we have association
with of jeans with metabolites
and pull together they provide specific
Association of operations in customs
this is a year of approach of combining
different types of tables or mix tables
multi-omics data mutation tables made 18
tables
expression micro micro RNA remedy Big
Data clinical data for patients all
together in order to find this triple
Association as a subset of of one
features a subset of another three
features and these two subsets are
linked because they they're in the same
class before the same distance methods
or very close distance matrixes between
nations please next slide okay on this
slide you can see matrixes couple of
matrixes where which are very similar so
they I like it according to put some
positive normal X 4 or negative score
the negative is doing positive resist
array if told for instance of the set
second row you can see that some
specific patient just separated it's
very negative so very far from opossums
so this is very vertical Green Line and
horizontal grid line okay so this is
actually what what the problem is
it produces and on the next slide is
next slide
we can see some results of this type of
analysis here cell - breast cancer cell
lines we're taking altogether 49 cell
bands and they were analyzed by this
basis method what was found is that
there is a very separate sample which is
called here HCC - OH - and this is left
up pen
it is very separate from all others what
how will it was detected it was detected
according to gene expression later I
support especially the mutation score
theta this is actually score of mutate
islands of mutation and school scores of
islands of RNA if to go to these
pictures we can see for the first four
selected genes which defined separation
of this process individual sample gene
expression is extremely hard for it was
in this segment only in this specific
group group of jeans after annotation of
these genes they add this group is
enriched by olfactory receptor
activities at the same on the right with
either form expression again the same
patients as the same sample is separated
from all others it has extremely high
expression average expression across all
other homes
participating in the group the same
story is with mutation score
in the same fashion this has very high
score across all mutations regions
mutation regions with which were
selected in the group so this is average
mutation score and this is much much
higher than others but only for this
specific group of mutation reviews and
the same as Aaron name so of course this
is interesting to understand what what
does it mean what what what the schedule
was this specific same way and it
appears after analysis of entire o'haven
by this way we got hundreds of this
subgroups and and typically this is only
one one cell line in the group but on
the next slide please next slide you can
see that the program detected species
even of three samples together three
samples together are very separated
according to the group genes a group
isoforms a group of mutation regions and
aromanian y3 not one okay it appears
that all these three are eternally
derived from the same page so this
specificity of gene expression either
for this is a memory of a specific
patient from which this three cell lines
were direct okay
next slide please this is application of
the same method to to another type of
data taken from TCGA data base and
here seventy-three triple negative
breast cancer patients were taken and
after that that out there was a play and
the algorithm found this triple
associates not not triple but multiple
Association
it means group of genes group of
isoforms group of mutation mutation
Islands and all of them are providing
the same separation of four patients
from all others and this four patients
are listed on the left up upper left
panel ACA WG c p a1 C 3 and so on
ok what's the meaning presented it
should be studied through annotation of
genes or considering what what kind of
mutations for positional precipitations
or position of this iowans mutation
because here scores of islands were the
next slide the next slide is showing the
same data said but here gene expression
and either form expression and mutations
for selected only one page and here
mutation score is extremely low in this
page lower left panel but expression of
genes are very high average expression
over the set and against there are
several other examples here next slide
please
here a couple of patients was selected
and you can see that this couple is
indeed separated on the right separated
from all others this is PC pictures and
according to averages the separated
averages of actually this is tuned to
omics data where you've used RNA editing
and expression of isotopes so according
to a expression of isin form we can see
that this processes which are specific
illness patients are related from those
places and everything anything more or
less uniformly distributed over the
genome so since this is a change of
course but already biological change to
understand what is the specificity of
this patients and if we know clinical
data about the patient's okay we can say
something what houses clinical data are
related to the RNA editing processes
here or gene expression process next
slide please
okay here in a special selection based
on mutation combined with with gene
expression three majors were selected as
separated from all others and what is
interesting that here mutations are
condensed in chromosome 22 and and 3 and
there are some publications on the left
upper left related to some specific uses
concepts in breast cancer triple
negative breast cancer okay next slide
this is another example again separation
of two to patients and based on
combining or mistake of mutation and is
a
isoform expression and here according to
either forms we can see some supervening
ordering and mutations are again
concentrated in promise in chromosome 22
injury okay so this is I would say that
this is powerful method and we have
several public domain methods for gr44
multi-omics integration like I'd lost of
groups plus in the Alliance's several
other algorithms but the best of sin I
trusted who was can select only actually
only one subset of patients somehow
separated
or clustering to victory by our method
we can detect tons hundreds different
cases probably some of them are noisy
but majority looks as is directly
biologically okay
the next slide next slide please
can you show them slip
so actually turn on his doing his time a
little bit oh yeah okay this is a
systems biology modeling session so this
is okay here we have examples of
modeling group of viral infection viral
infection when actually two viruses
together in one cell one major - what
web time and the last ones is defective
interfering particles so a portion of
the genome of this virus is in immediate
it's equation is if this defective
defective particle can be therapeutic
bath but it means to delay infection of
while right or eliminated this is this
objective
okay next slide oh businesses there are
several approaches we used and here's
approach with ordinary differential
equations for sales for virus particles
for intracellular viral genome for
capsid proteins which is actually
repetition between the I particles and
well that viruses is going on for capsid
proteins and in vivid and the hostak
model and we actually this pipelines I
lose a game exactly the same as
previously and with these pipelines
we can define parameters of organ system
we can perform parameter fittingly to
talk to them to
we can play with okay maybe next leg
okay here on this slide how fitting to
to experimental data is performed for
this system of the equations or linear
differential equations okay this is
relatively good fitting and on the next
slide people can study the system
preparing posterior distribution of
parameters on the right
[Music]
looking to sin satirical parameters how
statistically significant our parameters
different parameters for instance here
the first parameter II is very far from
zero it means that this is very
significant part of creation and on the
left panel for solutions which are close
to experimental data we can understand
what are the dependencies between
parameters I mean we it means user use
are just plain which with the same
pipelines as we are waiting so
dependences between parameters presented
as Bayesian networks on some positive
and negative influences parameters to
parameters from other parties next slide
please
okay another section of the platform is
for for 3d the 3d structures and
the basis here is local similarities of
three-dimensional structures of my
labels and proteins next slide please
okay so the typical metal is like there
and actually we are calculating some
physical chemical qualities of atoms
based on three dimensional distribution
of atoms here and particularity of atoms
and after that instead of
three-dimensional structures we're
presenting Malabo as a set of some
linear strings strings of these keys
this physical chemical piece and based
on this representation of money or any
any three-dimensional structure for
instance structure of protein please
next slide we can find local similar
where this linear representation are
similar like like like alignment of
signals this is on the next slide and on
the next slide we can see that after
finding this local local local
alignments local vinieron alignments as
three dimensional alignment would be
easily arranged and actually
superposition so here on the next on
this slide you can see how atoms of two
metals are corresponding to each other
based on [ __ ] the linear
representation of say dimensional
structure where each atom has some kids
like hydrogen bond acceptor electro
positive
so they imagine there is a curricular
making each other and based on this
meeting we can secure
and hopefully quality of superimposition
which is here like certain tasks or
certain position okay based on this
score people can screen levels huge
libraries of mannequins with one model
of interest for instance Sundra in order
to find my nipples which are not only
similar in three-dimensional geometric
releasable
but also to the physical chemical
chemical world with physical chemical
qualities of their others so probably by
this way if you if you know some some
some drug for instance you can find huge
databases computationally other
variables which can work similarly to
this drug and after that to perform
pharmaceutical testicles just of course
just easy GP activity of this my
deficiency
okay next slide also the same technique
can be can be used in order to find
putative position for talking and and
the next slide is okay some some some
writing where the gun to one protein
appear okay with high probability will
be regard to another protein here for
your three original account was prostate
okay so this is this is sample were you
what platform is drink
the major major point here is that even
even the Keith get can play with a
platform just pressing randomly pressing
buttons but not randomly because what
form is suggested for each four star
button
what makes button could be pressed and
by this way a biplane can be prepared
and after that a person will get a
result and this is a way to see what
what the result
[Applause]